an eighteen-year-old
african-american male joined the United
States Air Force and was assigned to
Mountain Home Air Force Base and was a
part of the air police squadron upon
first arriving there the first goal that
I had was for me to identify an
apartment so I could bring my wife and
my new baby
Melanie out to join me in Idaho I
immediately went to the personnel office
and talking with the guys in personnel
they said hey no problem finding an
apartment in Mountain Home Idaho the
people down there loved us because they
know if they have an airman who's coming
in to rent one of their apartments
they'll always get their money and that
was a really important thing he says so
here's a list of people that you can
call and then they will then allow you
to select the apartment that you want so
I got them this I made the call lay the
answer on the other end and I told her
what I wanted she said oh great you
called she said we have four or five
apartments available right now she said
do you want a one bedroom or two bedroom
then she said let's not talk about that
just come on down select the apartment
that you want we'll sign the contract
and you'll have keys in your hand to get
your family out here right away
so I was excited jumped in my car went
downtown and knocked on the door when I
knocked on the door the woman came to
the door
and she looked at me and she said can I
help you I said yes I'm the person who
called about the apartments I was just
coming down to make my selection she
said you know what I'm really sorry but
my husband rented those apartments and
didn't tell me about them I said you
mean he rented all five of them in one
hour she didn't give me response and
what she said was this she said why
don't you leave your number and if we
have some openings I'll give you a call
needless to say I did not get a call
from her nor did I get any responses
from the other people that they gave me
on the list where I could get apartments
so as a result of that and so
rejected I went back to the base and I
talked to the squadron commander
his name was McDowell major McDowell
said maybe McDowell I need your help
I told him what happened and here's what
he said to me he said James I would love
to help you he said but you know the
problem we can't make people rent to
folks that they don't want to rent to
and besides we have a great relationship
with people in the community and we
really don't want to damage that he said
so maybe this is what you should do he
said why don't you let your family stay
home because you do know you get a
30-day leave so once you're here you can
go home to your family spend 30 days and
then come on back needless to say that
didn't resonate for me so after leaving
him I went back to personnel and talking
to the clerk he said Jim I think I have
a solution for you
he said there's an airman who's leaving
and he has a trailer he said if you
noticed and mounted home there are
trailer parks and trailers all over the
place he said you can buy his trailer
and you probably get a really good deal
because he wants to get out of town as
soon as possible he said and that would
take care of your problem and that would
provide the solution for you so I merely
jumped in my car went downtown saw the
trailer it was a small trailer but under
the circumstances I said that that was
the best thing that I could do so I
bought the trailer and then I asked him
I said can I just leave the trailer here
and that would take care of all my
problems I wouldn't have to have to find
another trailer park he said before I
say yes to that I need a check with
management so I got back to the base he
called me back the management said what
no you can't leave the trailer here
because we have promised that slot to
some other people and that was strange
to me because there were several other
slots that were open but it just so
happens that he had promised that slot
to someone else so what I did and he
said you shouldn't worry Jim because
there are a lot of trailer parks so I
put out another exhaustive list of going
to trailer park so I went to one after
another after another and I got the same
kind of rejection there that I received
when I was looking for the apartment and
as a result some kind of comments that
they made to me in addition to
saying that they didn't have any slots
open one person said Jim the reason why
we can't rent to you
he said we already have a Negro family
in the trailer park he said and it's not
me cuz I like you people he said that's
what I did to my Chapel - he said but
here's the problem if I let you in the
other tenants will move out and I can't
afford to take that kind of a hit so he
said I just can't rent to you even
though that was discouraging it didn't
stop me I kept looking and I looked at
the far end of the town and Mountain
home and it was a small trailer park I
mean really small trailer park it didn't
have any paved roads in it it didn't
have the concrete slabs it didn't have
spin seemed to proportion off your
trailer slot from other chiller slots it
didn't have a laundry facility but the
conclusion I reached at that moment was
I didn't have a lot of other options so
I called my wife and I said we're gonna
make this one work and we moved into it
and we became home owners and Mountain
Home Idaho and of course eventually
things settled down four years after
that I received papers to move from
Mountain Home Idaho to a place called
Goose Bay Labrador we won't even talk
about that
it was another bigger case over so my
challenge then was to get my family from
Mountain Home Idaho to Sharon
Pennsylvania that wasn't a problem
because we had just purchased a
brand-new automobile my mother called
said we'll fry she'll fly out she'll be
with us as we drive she'll help us
manage the children so she came out
hurry now let's put a lot of food
together for the trip that morning we
left about 5:00 a.m. great trip having a
great time good conversation somewhere
around 6:30 7 o'clock we got a little
bit tired and said why don't we get a
motel so we can rest and then have a
early start in the morning so we were
looking at numbers of motels as we drove
down the road and we saw one was a great
big bright flashing line that says fakin
C's vacancies vacancies so we stopped in
they were in the parking lot I went
inside when I walked inside the lady was
just finishing up one contract with some
folks some other people were coming in
behind me and so I walked up to the
counter and she said how can I help you
I said I would likely to the motel for
the evening for my family she said you
know I'm really sorry I just rented the
last one we will not have any more until
the morning she said but if you go down
the road about hour 45 minutes there's
another trailer park down there I said
yeah but you still have the vacant seats
life on it is flashing she said oh I
forgot and she reached over and turned
the light off then she looked at me and
I looked at her there were other people
in the room she kind of looked at them
no one said anything so I just got the
hint and I left one outside to the
parking lot and I told my mother and I
told my wife and also Melanie I said
well it looks like we're going to have
to drive a little bit further down the
road to get to be able to sleep tonight
and we did drive down the road but just
before we took off and pulled out of the
parking lot guess what happened the
light came back on and it said they can
see vacancy vacancy we were able to find
a nice place it wasn't our preference
but it was secure and it was clean and
so we had a great sleep that night the
piece that's important about that is
that we had similar kinds of experiences
from Idaho all the way through to
Pennsylvania where we were ejected from
hotels motels and restaurants but we
made it to Pennsylvania got the family
settled everyone was glad to see the
kids I jumped on a plane shut off to
Goose Bay Labrador which is another
story right
here it is 53 years later I now have
nine grandchildren two
great-grandchildren five of the
grandchildren are boys
I have master's PhD undergrad one in
medical school I have a couple that are
trendy you know they're almost there but
not quite I have one that has been in
cars now for eight years he doesn't have
a degree yet but he wants to be a
comedian so we're just trying to get him
to stay in school because they'd never
know just because you're funny at home
does not make you a comedian right but
the thing about it they're all good kids
no drugs no babies in high school no
crime so with that being a bad drug I
was sitting in my TV room watching TV
and they were talking about Ferguson and
all the hullabaloo that was going on and
all of a sudden one of the news
commentators get on the air and she said
in the last three months eight unarmed
african-american males have been killed
by police home white home owners or
white citizens for some reason at that
moment it just all hit mess it what is
it it is so insane what is the hatred
that's causing people to do these kinds
of things just then one of my grandson's
called he said granddad did you hear
what they said on TV yes I did he said
I'm just so confused he said we do
everything we do but it seems that
driving while black walking while black
talking while black it's just dangerous
what can we do we do everything that you
told us to do when stopped by the police
we place both hands on the steering
wheel at the 12 o'clock position if
asked to get identification
we tell them I am slowly reaching over
into the glove compartment to get my ID
when poured out of the car to be
searched when
on the ground to be searched when our
trunks are open to be searched we don't
push back we don't challenge because we
know you've told us don't you challenge
the police after it's over call us and
we'll be the ones who challenge he said
and this is the piece that really bugs
me he said our white friends our buddies
we kind of hang together when they hear
about these kinds of things happening to
us they say why do you take it you need
to push back you need to challenge you
need to ask them for their
identification and here's what the boys
have been taught to tell them we know
that you can do that but please do not
do that while we're in the car because
the consequences for you is
significantly different than the
consequences for us and so as a
grandparent what do I tell my grandsons
how do I keep them safe how do I keep
them alive as a result of this people
have come to me and say Jim are you
angry and my response to that is this I
don't have the luxury of being angry I
don't have the luxury of being angry and
I also know the consequences of being in
rage so therefore the only thing that I
can do is to take my collective
intellect and my energy and my ideas and
my experiences and dedicate myself to
challenge at any point in time anything
that looks like it might be racist so
the first thing I have to do is to
educate the second thing I have to do is
to unveil racism and the last thing I
need to do is do everything within my
power to eradicate racism in my lifetime
by any means necessary
the second thing that I do is this I
want to appeal to Americans I want to
appeal to their humanity to their
dignity to the acidic pride and
ownership to be able to not react to
these heinous crimes in an adverse event
but instead
to elevate your level of society to
knowledge your level of societal
awareness and society to consciousness
to then collectively come together all
of us come together to make sure that we
speak out against and we challenge any
kind of insanity any kind of insanity
that makes it okay to kill unarmed
people regardless to their ethnicity
regardless to their race regardless to
the diversity makeup we have to
challenge that it doesn't make any sense
in the only way that I think we can do
that is through a collective we neither
have black and white and Asian and
Hispanic just to step forward and say we
are not going to accept that kind of
behavior anymore
you